yeah welcome to this video playing oops
playing default yeah i'm playing a blitz
game once again five minute against the
beautiful mind from Switzerland right
yes it's really the unique Swiss flag
not something similar okay now we have
fun Slav plate on this line with queen
bee three leading to learn to quiet game
but termini it still has some some bite
to it Black has taken on c4 so white
hasn't has a scepter pawn to enjoy da
deep on let's see there on how to
continue development the nylon d2 is up
to sleep not well placed okay let's see
maybe on Queen B 6 I can go nite c4 I
don't mind the double porn gym but Queen
B 6 looks like a very natural means this
is also probably a theoretically
explored position interesting
okay rook e1 this prepares before I want
to have after efore Bishop f3 or
whatever Knight f3 covering the default
square and if he goes queen dee 5 now I
play Queen c2 and then you for next yeah
maybe maybe you should still do that
just taking quite some time at least I'm
not so far behind on the clock in
general the night on be sixths not
particularly well placed yeah as
mentioned this was my idea only wonder
where our midst okay I wondered briefly
what Queen d3 but Quincy to is probably
that the more natural move gap e form is
the idea we should f5 that still if all
it has not enough control over the e4
square well if I was a nice to get in ok
yeah i wonder if i should play it
immediately out of them if there's some
point to a different move water and
maybe age three first you know and now
if form
hmm I'm wondering about c5 that coming
c5 move hmm ok but at the moment that
the queen is detected it does not have a
particularly great square if firm let
goes to e5 I can play Knight be three
maybe yarn i p3 is the move that I'm
going to play anywhere here certainly
because I'd like to prevent see higher
and prepare Knight e5 covering the
default square first b3 often it's not a
great square for online but he had to
make some sense controlling c5 and 85
and it allows 95 the Queen on this
happen that's really really a bit bit
badly placed okay a form you know well
should I play G 495 grabbing the bishop
era it's not bad yeah c'mon let's not be
too sophisticated about that getting the
bishops as is something ok let's just
take it and maybe now Bishop is three
intending a safe night c5 with default
covered yeah this looks like
quite comfortable position okay he even
takes them I don't want to have this
square on d6 the question is some how to
continue now f4 f5 maybe you will play
e5 of course and I wonder f4e 5 f-5 this
is this is a good idea it's probably
keeping some edge on the other hand e5
that got here maybe you can play a 59 f
8 and 9 26 oh um I think plague f4 f5
after a 5 is a good idea because it
helps to control the center wow this I
didn't expect that's really very passive
okay well II 597 is not okay if I've
okay but now now I can plane rook to the
60 95 I have the exchange sac that is
very interesting okay let's let's do
that
night b5 I just play you five if he
takes the exchange I will take with the
sea pong and they have a great great
pawn yet and quite quite nice initiative
on both flanks yeah I cannot play c5
because b7 hangsen going to ya not sure
what this is doing just activate just
activate here it's not threatening to to
sacrifice on e5 or something like that I
just want to play h5 break up break open
the edge file if it moves the f porn
there's always g6 hanging so this is not
easily playable be too I'm not running
come on now i can give the check first
if i play rook rook takes there's f5
first is check probably
Master they can play five mmm that's not
necessary maybe first this attack and
then group takes age five I can play g6
now yeah well still i can take Luke's
you wanna this this is still quite good
for white the d6 bond is just just very
very strong
yeah b7 Hanks difficult to defend yeah I
think this is very good for white
probably this isn't in the best line but
it's it's good
yeah the nidus under so much pressure
check time morning check black reason
yeah I can just get the we could have
played your king seafoam just grab the
b3 but the bit quicker yeah difficult
difficult game but after the exchange
second black is under really huge
pressure I thought that Queenie 7 really
surprised me I mean white should be
better in any case but if I am I thought
would be basically forced then my idea
was to play f5 gaining even more space
but of course this is not not so easy
the idea is to control e6 so that he
cannot use this route to activate the
night and basically trying to take away
all possible squares from the Knights
however he can take care and after he
takes not my intention but after he
takes he's got this Square and G takes
this was what I wanted to play there's
the smooth and yeah there's also a
square that's not clear at all this is
what you should have played hard to tell
if this is really great for me with two
bishops are nice but it's not clear cut
it all maybe
some some other other approach yeah okay
maybe maybe I should have played that
one and I also have this idea to combat
this Knight f6 to f8 to e6 idea
something like that for example and now
let's let's say here then their various
ideas also Quincy three to put some
pressure on b5 very tricky okay but this
this was this was quite clear that if I
was coming here that here's a question
he could also just ignore that and go
night c7 to d5 then there's always this
rook right inside this position but
tricky really took it when this gives
white a really big compensation this
paunch and is very strong and 36 bonus
very good young and to look at the night
it's very difficult to activate this
piece you would love to play Knight b6
to d5 but you're never ever going to get
them very difficult with the bishop only
three being so strong yeah I went for
the H porn Porsche and probably i
mistimed it somewhat but to this point
it's probably all right but here check
okay the computer or the computer what's
the play exactly like a plate Bishop d3
amazing aah what aah this is very nice
of course I didn't see it here i can
take on age 5 computer takes and then
queen age 7 is just deadly queen a jade
mate and he's got such a such a
constraint position that he has no way
to defend it this
great didn't see that at all after f5
you have g6 store threatening the maid
fantastic move group takes h5 didn't
didn't consider that at all I mean this
is also very good for white but your
guides for h5 is obviously stronger here
it's basically toast like has has no
defense against this active active
pieces alright thanks for watching